والان الى موضوع يشغلنا كثيرا حقيقه وهو
الذكاء الاصطناعي هو يهدد الذكاء البشري
ويضعه في خانه الخطر وهذا ما وصلت اليه
تحذيرات عده بشان استخدام برنامج الدردشه
الالي
وهو الذي يشغل العالم فاخر استخدامات هذا
التطبيق اتحتها مؤسسات تعليميه للبكالوريا
الدوليه للطلاب في كتابه مقالاتهم وبحسب
صحيفه جاردين البريطانيه احتماليه الغش
المستند الى تشات جي بي تي ازعجه المعلمين
والاكاديميين ممن يعتبرونها خطرا على ذكاء
الطلبه البكالوريا الدوليه التي سمحت بهذا
التطبيق الذكي واجهت الانتقادات بتشبيه
السرقه الادبيه في البرنامج بالتعامل مع
الغشاشين واضافت ان الطلاب سيقتبسون من
المحتوى الذي
ويستخدمون مهاراتهم لتقييم النص واجراء
تعديلات قد فاتته ياتي ذلك وسط تحضيرات من
ان يسهم الروبوت بزياده انتشار المعلومات
الزائفه وايضا بالتلاعب بالراي العام يذكر
ان
تقنيه مجانيه طرحت في نوفمبر الماضي وهي
روبوت يستطيع الاجابه على اسئله بشكل
تفصيلي ودقيق كما يستطيع ايضا كتابه
موضوعات صحفيه كامله
[موسيقى]